1, 2, 3, 1, có trưa mà sao?
Anh của...
Bạn cứu đời đi, đời rồi?
Trời rồi.
Một đời này.
Tụng tụi này...
Tụng lắm của...
Chợ, trở nó có trở...
Chợ, trở, trở, trở, trở, trở...
Tụng tụi trở và đại ăn nhằm.
Chợ, trở, trở, trở...
Quái gì vậy?
Rồi, Rồi, Rồi...
Vậy mình ấy là...
Thôi, chứ?
Chúng tôi nhớ.
Chúng tôi đã kìm đón này.
Tìm này,
Tìm,
Cô, cà dân hãy tìm này là.
Thôi, chứ?
Tại vì chúng tôi lại ngon đến.
Đúng rồi, thôi, chứ?
Tại vì chúng tôi cũng mới muốn được đúng không?
Thôi, chứ?
Tại vì sao?
và tổng ai đánh mò anh tìm lấy
trong người anh từ nó trá lấy
bụi bây giờ không, sổ lấy
anh từ nó đúng không đúng
anh nói là môi các người anh từng lời
để gà lái không?
bằng mong nhiều của người màu nhỏ
anh
Hôm qua 1, 2 năm nay, người khu trăm 2 mi sấu
có 1 tình thả tính chứ bước
đâm vị vô xếp phá đường dây mà tuy luôn tình
bắt có tăng của tự cầm đồng
tung giữ khó phy nâm kêu gà mà tuy ra
cho có xin đấu trên chân an
Phòng cạnh rất là trách phòng bình bà tui đám hôm hôm chất chế với phòng cạnh rất cơ động và công an sảy và tình hát những chiếc hài được lượng tổ chức với bắt không chế đối tượng.
Còn đó, lực lượng trức năng đã bắt có trang phần bánh giữ.
Xin năm mừng những chiếc chăm bệnh mấy mốt, chú xa in và tình hát những lối tượng cần đầu đường dây.
Tại nếu ở vời chiếc một phần bánh giữ, lực lượng công an thông dữ khó phy nhâm kêu gàm tinh kể mồ chẳng gì là mặt đối đá,
mấy tham phê tâm miệng của nhiều tâm bệnh phòng.
Có sinh đu chó xác, cũng thăm ra đường dây có bố tà không hôm, sinh là mình những chiếc chăm tâm miệng, chú tài phương rất có nước tình còn ngái,
lối tượng có nhiều tình an, dữ phá chẳng của các bà tui cho giữ tổ thịt và nghiệp bàn tình hát đến, để chiếc rau em bi pháp tội.
Các đối tượng xử tập khoảng năng tình hát để giang dịch, các giống mà tý tại như điều điểm và xí đạo nằm em tự thiện tệm mua bán ra hệng.
Mồ dụng điều tra, các bạn có ngàn còn ràng só hình vì tổ chức sử dụng tra phép chức mà tui của các đối tượng liên qua xe ra tại tệ tỉ còn hái.
Tên bộ tăng và trường mà tui tiền, khiến thái gì đâu, phong tiền và tự lượng liên quan đánh đột nghiên phòng,
khoảng lý theo đúng quy định để phục vụ cùng các đối tra.